hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor i've been investing
in property for 12 years
and in this video i'm gonna be answering
your property investment
questions so i've got a whole bunch of
questions here from youtube comments
what i want you to see if you're
watching right now though is
while i'm answering these questions
listen and i want you to be
commenting your questions below in the
comment box why
because i'm going to answer your
property investment questions
next week on sunday at 7 pm so comment
below
i'll be answering next week also don't
just comment your question
but also subscribe and turn the
notification bell on
otherwise i'll answer your question and
you won't even be able to know i'm
answering it because you
you haven't been pinged so let's see
what we had last week by the way please
smash the like button if you enjoy my
videos
and you know what i really believe
there's not many people that put
themselves out on youtube
who've got experience in the industry as
i say i've been investing for over 12
years i'm financially independent
i've got a lot of properties i've
trained tens of thousands of students
so take this opportunity ask your
property investment
your property your finance your business
questions below i'm looking forward to
answering okay so abdul said
i'm looking to purchase a property to
convert to a hmo since you're hate since
you're a hmo expert
okay i was wondering if you could
confirm if there was a minimum room size
to convert a two bedroom into a three
bedroom
by adding partitioning wall to great
extra bedrooms uh yeah it's a good thing
to do at abdo you can create extra
bedrooms if you've got a really big
bedroom you can just chop it in half
so size wise for a hmo they need to be a
minimum of 70 square
feet so that's the minimum size if
there's
a communal area 70 square feet if
there's no communal area then a hundred
square feet so
i imagine you'll have a lounge or
something they can share hope that helps
good job and good luck on the conversion
vinnie morris
hey man i have my own residential
property that i rent a room
out in i have approximately 25
equity 50 000 pounds but my question is
would i be able to do a brr
using a bridging loan then live in that
property then recycle that money into a
brrsa
okay um let me just understand your
question i think i understand your
question so brr is buy refurbished
refinance
the thing is you've already bought it so
you couldn't really do a brr on it
because you've
well you've already bought it you've got
it on a residential mortgage at the
moment you're renting a room out
good you can do that and you don't pay
tax on that either you don't if you rent
a spare room out in your house you don't
pay tax
so your question is really your question
is should you just refinance it
and the answer is because you're not
gonna be able to well
you don't need a bridging loan because
you already own it you only need a
bridging loan if you're needing
development finance to push the value up
but presumably it's already in good
condition
and you can't refinance it because
you've only got 25 equity in it anyway
so my my my uh
answer would probably be i mean sa
service accommodation that's another
story
if you can do a service accommodation
maybe refinance it onto a different
mortgage that allows you to rent
all the rooms that serviced
accommodation that could be a solution
but
you're gonna struggle to i wouldn't get
a bridging loan on that property it
doesn't make any sense
um anyway i hope that helps sorry i
can't be more helpful
if vinnie if you've got a follow-up
question if you want to explain your
scenario a little bit
more i'm happy to do my best to help
okay winston
winston simpson says a great content i
watched one of your videos from a year
ago
yesterday great good that you happened
to watch that
it was about taking equity from your
residential property to use
buy to let okay on the video you gave an
example of a skint lady who had three
hundred thousand pounds equity in her
house and you told her to get a 75
mortgage 225 000 on the house
you didn't explain how she'd be able to
get this mortgage if she was already
struggling
someone asked me this question on that
video but you didn't reply
replying to these sorts of questions
will make your methods more transparent
and fill in the gaps for the layperson
um all right fair enough winston i you
know what i um
i'm sorry i didn't reply i don't
actually recall
that lady um so how did she get a
mortgage
on her property i mean listen i don't
know
maybe she spoke to a broker and she
might have been
skint but that doesn't necessarily mean
that she didn't have a job maybe she had
a job
um i don't know however i often advise
people in that situation to actually
sell their house
if you've got a a house that you're
owning cash and you're living in it
and it's a big house and you've saved up
all your life and you've got this big
house that your kids have lived in and
now your kids have moved out and you've
got this big house owned in cash
might make sense to just sell the house
and you're not going to pay capital
gains tax because you
have lived in the house it's your home
and then take all the cash
and then invest it in property and then
all that money that you're making from
the rents
used to rent somewhere and you'll rent
somewhere probably much nicer
and rather than only one houses you've
got lots of houses so that's often my
advice
but in that particular scenario i'm not
sure i don't know how she got the
mortgage
if she was skin maybe she was skint but
she just had a job
but most people that have a job all of
their income goes straight
to expenses anyway the average salary is
about two and a half thousand pound a
month
the average expenses is about two and a
half thousand pound a month so you can
be skinned but still have a job so i'm
not
quite sure i hope that helps winston
thank you for your question if you've
got questions don't forget comment your
questions below i know i want to answer
them
lewis edwards hi samuel i'm 15 years old
good for you
and was just wondering how do you write
a good business plan or maybe you can do
a video on it
it depends what the purpose of the
business plan is is the business plan
for a
for a bank because you want to get a
business loan is it for an investor
uh you want to get money or is it for
you if the business plans for you
i would i would i would literally keep
it really simple i'd write down what are
your personal goals
i i.e i want to live in this kind of a
house i want to take this many holidays
a year i want to give this much to
charity
what's your ideal personal life look
like
and then how much is it going to cost to
finance that personal
your personal goals and that's where
your business goals come in okay well
property is going to be my vehicle
and i need x amount of money to fund my
personal life
and now you've got the amount of money
it's now case of the vehicle's property
but how are you going to get that money
and it's just a clear breakdown of
exactly what you're going to do you're
also going to
need to do a risk assessment on the bad
things that can happen
and you might think oh risk assessment
that sounds really complicated it's not
it's just
write down on a piece of paper all the
things that could go wrong and the ways
that you could lose money
and then how are you going to prevent
that from happening and how are you
going to de-risk it best you can so
all this is is basically a business plan
and we do help people our students on
the academy we help them write a
business plan
which which is for their purposes but as
i said it depends what the purpose is
you're 15. um just get just get right in
one now and it's really good to be clear
on your goals
because most people that go into
property and they haven't got a business
plan it's good that you're saying this
you know oh i'm just going to start in
property it's like well what's your plan
if you haven't got a plan
what do they say if you plan to fail
then you fail to plan so good for you
all right next callum i bought my first
buy to let in cash
last year i'm now looking to refinance
and buy my second
only problem is i don't have a job as i
went away traveling
i don't have access to mortgages is
there anything i can do to refinance now
or will i have to find a job first
calum if it's a buy gillette property
they're probably not that bothered about
your income
i mean i've known people and this is a
bit like i'm answering uh winston's
question now about getting a mortgage
if you're buying a buy to let mortgage a
buy to let property and you need a buy
to let mortgage
doesn't matter what your income is now
i've known people that have got five
thousand pounds a year as their
income they're self-employed so the
income's not even particularly stable
but they've still got mortgages and the
reason is is because if you're buying a
house to rent out
the lender is going to look at that
house and they want to know how much is
that rent going to be
in that house how much is your tenant
going to pay is this house going to be
able to sustain itself
because if the house sustains itself the
investor is going to be able to rent it
out and pay the mortgage
now if you're buying a house to live in
that's different because that's not
that's not an asset that's a liability
the house isn't going to be able to pay
you anything so you're buying a house to
live in
the lenders care about how much you're
earning you're buying a house
to rent out they care more about the
rental
ability the rental capacity of the house
so you probably don't need to get a job
just to get a buy to let mortgage
i'm sure there's easier ways to do it i
hope that helps all right
next i fuss what are your thoughts on
the government imposing eviction bans i
think it's stupid i'm angry about it
because i i got it for a time but now i
think they're taking the mickey i think
it's bad for everybody i think that it's
going to
put people off um buying properties to
to rent out
which is going to mean that there's less
accommodation i think that people that
have got
properties that are buy to let's are
going to switch them over to service
accommodation
and get more money and ultimately it's
going to end up penalizing the tenants
because the tenants are going to have no
way to live and the tenants that don't
pay rent right now are going to end up
getting evicted it's just going to be
down the line
and then when they get evicted they're
going to have bad credit and they're
going to have nowhere to affordable to
live because landlords are going to have
all the service accommodation instead
and being creative and i think it's
going to mess the economy up and i'm
angry about it
and i did a bit a whole video about this
i'll pop it up as a card right now but
yeah i'm angry
okay um winner 2021 samuel
a question mate can you please comment
on
what the purpose of a limited company in
property is
cheers mate yeah winner the purpose of a
limited company is
i guess there's two main purposes i'm
sure there's a lot more than two but off
top of my head number one is it protects
you it ring fences you
so if you're buying through a company it
just means that
from from a liability point of view from
a position if you're doing like rent to
rent and things like that
they're not going to sue you if they
slip down the stairs they're going to
see your company so it just protects you
a little bit but more than anything is
for tax reasons so if you buy for a
company
you can pay yourself in dividends which
are a much more tax efficient way to pay
yourself
so you're you'll pay yourself a salary
of 11 000 pounds you don't pay tax on
the first 11 000 pounds
thereafter you're going to pay yourself
in dividends where the tax is quite
small
but also if you buy through a company
section 24 doesn't apply which means
that you can claim more as
tax-deductible i.e
mortgage payments you can't claim
interest mortgage payments as
tax-deductible if you're buying as an
individual
so there's tax advantages there's
liability advantages so it makes sense
to probably buy for a company but i
would suggest speaking to an accountant
before you make those types of decisions
okay i'll maybe just do one or two more
um
what we got what we got what we got is
code deal sourcing
with an established seller a good way to
start in property i make about sixteen
hundred pound a month for my outgoings
of thirteen hundred pounds a month and
saving for a house will take years
if so where do you recommend i source
buy to let and brr deals in any
particular cities
you're right it will take years i said
this before most people's income is the
same as their outgoings
yours is your you have 300 pound a month
disposable income so you can save 300
pound a month
how much is an average house 200 grand
let's say you buy 100
house awesome what's the deposit 25
grand plus stamp duty plus
little other bits and bobs legal fees
you need about 30 35 grand to buy a
cheap house
how long is that going to take you if
you're saving up 300 pound a month i
tell you how long forever
and then you're gonna buy it and then
what great you've got one house and
you're 45 years old
like whoopi do so that's why you need to
be an entrepreneur as well as an
investor you need to make money as well
as investing money your question was is
code deal sourcing good
yes it is it's really good uh what
cities would you look for i'd find
investors and ask them what they're
looking for
and then go find it and then give it to
them that's what business is find out
what people want
then give it to them that's business if
you want to be a successful investor
find out what tenants want what they're
looking for buy it and offer it
you're a deal packager find out what
investors are looking for and then offer
it them
you know that's being an entrepreneur so
good luck with that
okay uh artist flow artist flow can i
remortgage a flat which i bought with
cash but it was a concrete and wasn't
mortgageable
oh if it's concrete construction there
is very few lenders that will lend it
depends on
it it depends there probably will be
some lenders that will but you might end
up having to pay a high interest rate
and you're going to be very limited
speak to a broker okay last one mw
2002 fitness says hi samuel
is samuel 365 still available as i am
now
finally 18 years old i'm so excited to
learn more and get my first property my
goal is to own 40 properties by the time
i'm 30
years old keep the videos up man so
inspirational and helpful hopefully the
accusations
stop listen accusations will never stop
okay
um but accusations mean nothing well
it's all about evidence and proof so
yeah i i have all the time people in the
comments you know samuel
is too good to be true or he's or this
he's or that uh mostly from people that
are either just jealous or trying to use
my name as clickbait
or people that have just never actually
done any of my training so not too
worried about accusations what i am
worried about is you getting on samuel
365. yes it's still available
costs a pound to join for seven days and
then it's 95 pound a month so now you're
18.
get on there you get mentoring coaching
training
for 95 pound a month which is crazy i'll
leave a link in the description but
folks
i hope you found this helpful thank you
so much for watching drop your comments
below
smash the like button turn on the
subscribe notification bell
and i will see you next time peace out
you